stream j'espère le quantième stream ont
fait la sueur sur la chaîne de ça fait
combien de jeudi qu on fait ça
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas mais ça fait
beaucoup de jeudi donc c'est cool et je
me prends du sol autre route est donc
prêt donc c'est rim sont toujours bien
cool et j'ai eu une nouvelle idée d'un
truc qu'on pourrait faire alors c'est
pas mon idée personnelle je regarde
juste un peu les scream que que les gens
font à gauche à droite voyaient genre je
m'inspire évidemment comme tout sport
deux fois j'ai mes propres aux idées
comme les pls par exemple mettre des prs
vivent ça c'est cool et parfois je
m'inspire de ce que je vois à gauche à
droite et des choses qu'on n'a pas
encore fait il pour un peut correspondre
à un truc qui me qui m'amuserait ou qui
me tenterait donc on a eu les stream
pédagogique 1 qui reviendront pas ce
qu'ils vous ont beaucoup plu et j'ai
envie de tester un autre truc c'est de
faire un peu des tactiques sur
l'entraîneur tactique mais je vais
attendre pour le moment qui est un peu
de gens qui arrivent
l'histoire qu'on fasse ses tactiques
ensemble alors je dois vous avouer un
truc direct je répèterai canton un peu
plus tôt durant ce que tu sais que y'a
personne qui arrive pile à l'heure donc
ce que je suis dans les cinq premières
minutes y'a personne qu'il entend de
toute façon à part les fidèles des
finales mais je suis pas très bon sur
l'entraîneur tactique principalement
pour une raison c'est que quand j'étais
gamin qu'il ait beaucoup d'entraîneurs
tactique pour progresser bien évidemment
genre faisait peut-être aller en moyenne
une heure par jour
j'étais très bon parce que j'ai la
motivation de les trouver et que je me
concentre à fond et tout et voit la fin
j'avais une motivation claire c'était
progresser aux échecs d'être meilleur en
tactique et donc je faisais beaucoup
d'exercices tactique de calcul pour
progresser là dedans et donc j'avais la
motive à fond aujourd'hui se trouve que
quand vous voyez blitz et je suis pas si
mauvais en tactique il me reste des bons
restes sarah je me débrouille même si
c'est plus mon point fort le calcul ça
j'en ai tellement tellement tellement
tellement fait que j'ai réussi à
construire une tactique et je compte
tuque
je suis à faire ma petite ma petite
sauce on va dire ma petite sauce
tactique mais sur les entraîneurs
tactique j'ai la flemme de calcul est
vraiment j'ai pas la motive je suis
souvent complètement à la rue du joint
par am je sais pas je suis devenu très
mauvais sur les entraîneurs tactique ce
qui m'empêche pas de bon dans les
parties et donc l'idée ce serait voilà
qu'on mette combattre l'entrée un
tactique qu'on réfléchisse un petit peu
ensemble à ce qu'on voit ce qu'on pense
que j'essaie de pas aller trop vite non
plus parfois je vais complètement
bloquée sur certaines tactiques comme je
disais j'ai du mal et ça vous aidera
peut-être mais on va essayer de faire ça
ensemble et j'essaierai quand je trouve
rapidement ne pas tout de suite dans la
réponse pour qu'on essaye de voir ça
ensemble
est ce que ça vous va et donc j'aurai
les deux chat à lui mais pas ouvert un
set sharp alors est ce que je cherche à
repousser sept chats ou c'est un autre
seul chat les sept chars puisque
équilibre à vous pour rien hier
hier j'ai envoyé du rêve je me suis fait
rêver moi même lire du coup ce qui
m'embête toujours quand je le fais rêver
c'est que je me dis tu t'es fait rêver
une fois après les gens attendent que tu
fasses aussi bien et puis bon c'est faux
ça n'arrive qu'une fois quoi alors
grégoire qui demande quand qu'on
commence à rennes à cannes un aréna
carennac qui ou pas ce soir et non
grégoire paris lighting pourquoi parce
que les arénas king c'est le lundi et le
mercredi à partir de 21h sur la chaîne
twitch de bitstream
tous les lundis et les mercredis georges
rate rien ou de merlin ou de gens
rentrés trois exactement 3 3 3 3 arena
king pendant pendant le stage à budapest
et il y en a une que je jouerai en
rentrant du trad donc l'aréna king de
retour on parlera machin ont tous cas de
la budapest mais mes arena king lundi
mercredi soir chaînes distribuées à là
on est allé mec
cette semaine a fait deux troisièmes
places très très honorable très très
honorable troisième place
franchement on est très heureux enfin
c'était c'était inespéré
c'était d'être résultat signe espérait
alors avant que tout le monde s'ennuie
je vais être une petite taxi quand il se
la chercher ensemble on est 2034 pour le
moment le mec a pris en bref 6 et sa
nounou et du coup j'ai une petite idée
perso mais je vais vous laisser
réfléchir à ce que vous pensez
alors j'ai eu deux idées jusqu'à
maintenant mais il y en a une qui me
paraît plus forte que l'autre en avant à
quoi vous pensez et qu'elle vous voyez
puis je vous dire un peu moins ce que le
début après je veux pas tout de suite
vous spoiler un petit peu réfléchir
ensemble
je pense à ce pôle est maintenant parce
qu'ils étaient des gens commencent à
répondre mais en gros ce à quoi j'ai
pensé au premier en premier c'était de
faire tour f8 hamas j'ai voulu faire des
flèches
aïe aïe aïe je préfère de frais je suis
rentré en tactique à main je ne savais
pas ça je vais vous montrer que ça
marchait pas attendez comment on fait
pour analyser je suis perdu est ce que
c'est bien cadré oui donc je vais vous
montrer que touré fuite
ça marche pas à cause d'eux a alors
l'idée c'était que sur tourcoing f8 y
avait pour point f8 tour prend la fuite
roy prend la fuite et s'en allait
pouvoir gagner avec le pion dès qu'ils
passaient donc c'est ce que j'allais
vous montrer
et donc j'ai pensé que le bon coup après
tout reprend m6 on sait que ses poulains
complètement spoil un manant c'était
pions d2 avec la menace de jouer tourer
et c'est une menace qui est très forte
ici parce que
[Musique]
parce que sur wajeha on aura des ans
dames passif et 3g 1 on va faire tourner
et il pourra plus éviter à des arts
dames c'est plus possible
et le truc qui pourrait faire peur là
dessus c'est de jouer 17 7 rue qui
pourrait être inquiétant parce que on va
menacer la tour mais après tout revin
les blancs ont pas le temps de jouer
tour des six pour menacer de faire la
demande et 8 passes 4 points f1 mat
donc la réponse était c'était des deux
que j'avais trouvé mais voilà on voulons
faire des flèches sans savoir qu'on ne
pouvait pas je me suis un petit peu
fourvoyé
vous avez bien compris ça va pas trop
rapide
on va passer au suivant
alors fermé ça on va passer au suivant
c'est un échec total
ah bah maintenant il me le refaire au
chievo bon et dans ce cas là là ça c'est
encore un autre coup on va faire tout un
échec
il va faire tour f1 et maintenant on va
réfléchir ça c'est une défense à
laquelle j'avais pas pensé alors c'est
pas idiot comme défense
l'idée c'est que si on fait tout reprend
f1 il va faire tourcoing f1 on va faire
tout ré fuite
alors se retourner à honorer tour 8 mai
va faire tour g1
maintenant il faut qu'on réfléchisse
tour pro f 1 tourcoing f1 touré fuite
tour g1 ça ça défend hockey du coup on
peut faire tout reprend d un tour prend
des 1 et tours 8
on est ok on fait tout reprendre un tour
prend d un don comprend la tour en d1
avec l'idée de faire tout re 8 et de
menacer tout romain maths et là on va
gagner et vous voyez la ligne que j'ai
calculé au début la ligne que j'ai
calculé au début qui était de jouer
tours.fr un tour prend 1 f1 est toujours
en fuite
avec l'idée du maître la tour en d1
finalement elle a servi puisque après
tour g1 j'ai vu que ça marchait pas et
donc ça veut dire que le bon coup c'est
tout reprendre vous comprenez ma logique
est bien entouré il va faire ou à f2 on
va faire tout reprendre et 1 et sur 17
on avait tous récents échecs très
important un c'est pas aller jusqu'au
bout mais on va mettre l'échiquier des
analyses et le truc c'est que on va
revenir on va revenir on va revenir là
on va revenir là on va redevenir la très
important ça aussi comme variante
surtout rui troisième tour un échec 3f
deux tours d 1 et sur 17 qui aurait pu
paraître marché on a tous rêvé un échec
qui permet de dames et sur échec au
prochain vous même si on n'aime pas sur
l'échec de toute façon on tient le pion
ça va pas trop dur
tranquille
allez on fait le suivant
alors ici c'est aux blancs de jouer et
oui j'arrive pas à faire les faits je
vais demander si on peut le faire alors
aux blancs de jouer alors déjà premier
truc qu'on voit c'est la case f6 pour le
cavalier c'est la russie ont fait
cavaliers ap six échecs fourchette à un
moment donné ça va gagner pour le moment
y'a g prend 1,6 donc personnellement il
ya deux trucs que j'ai envie de calculer
ici il ya même plus un truc que j'ai
envie de calculer mais le premier truc
genre si j'étais en glisse le truc que
je joue tempo c'est au tour j'ai
vraiment parce que je me rase tout
reprend j'ai cet échec qui va faire très
mal et je menace cavaliers f6 donc
honnêtement je vois pas trop comment y
défend donc tour gerin déjà je me dis
que c'est bon après le deuxième truc que
je regarderai si si j'avais le temps
c'est fou prend g7 en premier avec
l'idée sur roy prend j'essaie de faire
tourner un échec roi ait fuité cavaliers
f6 mais bon honnêtement leur second tour
g1 gagne direct l'appeler comme ça un
entraîneur tactique peut-être que
l'autre truc est plus fort mais à tour
g1 ça me paraît quand même violent se
tait relief si ça va être une triplette
on va tous menacés et six jours est
fluide là on va faire [ __ ] angers7
cavani f6 mais ça me met en difficulté
avec 130 ha tik c'est des fois j'ai un
peu de mal à ce moment là mais ce que
vous avez d'autres idées dans le chat et
son ado d'idées que tour g1 parce qu'il
ya d'autres trucs qui nous plaisent et
ce qu'il ya d'autres idées même si elles
sont pas bonnes on nous propose aussi
dans le chatt cavaliers f6 échec puis on
prend avec six tours j'ai un échec
roy ait fuité fou prend f6 mais bon il
va faire flouer 5 tonton alors y'a
tonton queen's nightly cavaliers si l'on
prend et fils tour g1 roux avait fuité
fou g7 alors attention au queen's aïn
parce que quand tu fais cavaliers ap six
pions prend tour j'ai un échec
roy et fuite tu ne peux pas mettre ton
four angers7
you cannot coude sur bishop angie c'est
van beek aux dérives de peau d'âne f 6
impasse qui influeront m6
faire très attention et ça s'est souvent
des erreurs qu'on voit en calcul donc
c'est intéressant ce que nous dit ce que
nous dit dans le chatt queen's night out
c'est à dire qu'ils se ils oublient le
pion f6 dansaert armes de calcul vous
voyez bien les mecs on est tous d'accord
is for getting 2.296 donc iso iso
footing de route angie one with the jack
king estate and analyses and is not
footing de bishop angie c'est ben quoi
je juge par un peu en anglais avec
l'accent français pour me faire plaisir
et il continue à calculer ça rame calme
il s'en fout complètement
ça ne m'intéresse pas mais donc ça c'est
rare typique un les tontons c'est une
erreur typique
donc on est tous sur tour g1 allons
attentes et moi j'ai pas calculé de plus
mais bon perso c'est ce que georges
acérées s'est résolu c'était tour g1
tout bêtement abondant gagne pas trop de
points l'eau parce qu'il fallait trop en
seconde un bon on aurait joué tempo
normalement et on menace cavaliers f6
qui est imparable
est ce que ça va pour tout le monde et
ce cas des questions je veux pas les
vilains je les lis aujourd'hui on est
tranquille
j'ai dit je viens de te découvrir c'est
très intéressant pour le coup bas merci
tu peux aller checker là la chaîne
youtube
la chaîne youtube blitz crime tu as déjà
700 vidéos tu peux te battre tu peux te
battre dans la dernière vidéo sur la
chaîne est très bien puisqu'on l'a fait
avec un joueur qui a été classé 18e
mondiale donc pas mal alors là les noirs
jouent dams et 7 alors déjà premier truc
on va identifier les menaces noir alors
le pion aux oeufs sains qu'il n'est pas
menacé puisqu'il est protégé la seule
menace ce serait cavalier ces deux
échecs mais après roi des deux ça va pas
bien loin parce qu'il ya pas d'autres
échecs pour les noirs donc en gros la
menace les noirs n'ont pas de menace
partant de là les mecs luc les noirs ne
semble pas pouvoir faire plus d'un échec
qu'est-ce que vous jouerez avec les
blancs le niveau lots de l'entraînement
là c'est 2020 on propose fois h6 dans le
tchat
bah écoutez
fois en six mois c'est le coût que
j'aurais joué 1 c'est logique partant du
fait que les noirs n'ont pas de menace
ça a l'air très fort on nous propose au
sida même si ça leur dame f6 je pense
qu'on peut te défendre avec des 5 es tu
devras à près de 9,6 des 5
la dame va couvrir la case de cet été 8
alors que fois çi sa menace mater sa
menace de gagner une qualité donc ça m'a
l'air plus précis d'un même si ce dessin
ou d'un même six cavaliers c6 d'ailleurs
aussi je regarde la nef six cavaliers
bbc6 le cavalier va couvrir les cases de
7 et des limites et il va attaquer le
curieux 5 donc fois-çi sa part être le
coup il fait des 5
mais bon là c'est toujours le moment un
peu dur sur l'entraîneur tactique mais
là le truc en partie avoir cédé 1,28 3
17 d'un point fc 3 3 bougez dame france
et cet échec est donc on échange les
dames et on se retrouve avec une
position complètement gagnante
après je sais pas si à mieux mais c'est
souvent là que je me plante on va faire
d'un point 9-8 hockey et c'est beau ça
va pas trop dur tranquille tranquille
alors là très haut blanc mais là j'ai
trouvé si simple j'ai pas trop pas
encore trouvé je veux c'est trouver en
premier
c'est intéressant je vais vous expliquer
après je voulais c'est un petit peu
cherché
je suis complètement galéré
j'entends réellement galéré à trouver ce
truc là en fait non je vais vous
expliquer un tube pourquoi je galère le
truc que j'ai vu de base c'était
d'essayer de faire qui fou prend m6 mais
le truc c'est que même après dame prend
un f6 sur cavaliers prend des quatre
fous prend des quatre on n'aura jamais
fou pranger 4 passes qu'adam problème de
maths
voyez à ce matin f2 qui me gêne un petit
peu donc cavalier prend des quatre ans
en premier c'est ce à quoi j'ai pensé
après avec l'idée mais surtout prend des
4 le truc c'est que si on fait fou prend
f6 il va jouer d'armes point m6 et quand
on a joué fou pranger cas tu aura de
nouveau des problèmes de maths
ok donc on a cette menace qui est un
petit peu chiante et qui nous empêche de
faire marcher sa donc maintenant ce à
quoi je pense c'est fou prend des cif ou
prend f6 dame prend un f6 et essayer de
placer un petit coup intermédiaire ici
alors qu'est ce que vous auriez comme
comme idée de quoi intermédiaire après
fou prend m6 d'un problème si ce n'est
que maintenant qu'on a identifié le
problème on va trouver la solution
donc après faux problème 6 d'un problème
fiscal coûts intermédiaires on peut
trouver alors jacques guers nuit
cavaliers des 5 c'est exact alors on va
aller maintenant un peu plus loin on va
faire fou prend un f6 cavaliers pro f 3
échecs intermédiaire alors sur cavaliers
pour un f3 échec intermédiaires on va
avoir envie de reprendre du pillon j'ai
pour attaquer le fou ensuite il va faire
dame prend f6 on pourra pas jouer pions
pranger 4 à cause de dame prend f2
j'espère que vous me suivez
et sur cavaliers des 5
il va jouer dam des quatre sur quoi on
pourra jouer pions pranger quatre dames
pro f 2 échecs roi des deux c6
pourchassé notre cavalier et menacé de
venir en trois avec le fou et tour est
fin et on va pouvoir tout paraît toutes
les menaces et faire des cours
intermédiaire bon alors on va voir on va
voir ce que ça donne mais
je pense que les gens qui ont résolu ce
truc là s'il à 2028 ont pas vu jusque là
on va voir fou pour un f6 dame prend un
f6 donc là nous on a dix cavaliers des
cinq belges dans cet ordre de coulage
est pas cachée du coup mais on va
imaginer qu'un dessin qui si ça paraît
logique intermédiaire dam des huit
équipes rang des quatre là franchement
check point comme t'es sympa
honnêtement on chez ce point comme il
est cool parce que pour moi la varende
de cet exercice la vraie variante site a
vu le truc jusqu'au bout d'après moi
c'est fou pro f 6 cavaliers pros f3
intermédiaire là du coup gpra f3 pour
maintenir la pression sur le fou dame
prend un fils pour moi c'est ça la
variante est calculé jusqu'au bout non
la chase points comme t'es cool
cavaliers des cinq menace la dam dam des
quatre remet une pression sur le pion à
f2 puis on prend g4 dame prend un f2 roi
des deux pour le moment on tient tous
ces six pour chasser le cavalier et tour
f1 pour moi c'est ça la variante à
trouver pour moi c'est sa rente à
trouver les mecs
pour voir jusqu'au bout donc c'était une
variante de cette cour ça va vous avez
bien suivi dans le chat c'est pas trop
dur s'applique pas trop mais regardez de
fou 3 pas possible elliott parce que
j'ai le cavalier qui tient tout donc
vraiment si vous voulez avoir la
tactique juste emmener pourquoi pas
kelly c'est cet échec parce que jusqu'à
6,7 et chaque croix 17 cavaliers prend à
ça me fait un peu peur pour ton roi
tonton dame e3 et chaque si tu fais 3 c3
je te fais d'amd 4 tu peux pas partir en
b3 parce que je te m'as tu t'es obligé
de revenir l'ail je te fais un perpète
bon si vous voyez quand je bouge x
parfois ne pas parler voire des
variantes ça à peu près des trucs comme
ça que je calcule mais jugez pas le
temps de vous le dire vous voyez on a
passé combien de temps sur cette
tactique qui va me le dire on a passé
bah non il me met pas le temps qu'on a
passé on a passé trois minutes 47 là
pour discuter de ça mais normalement on
glisse mon niveau il faut essayer de
qualifier des langues comme ça en fait
allez on va dire 30 35 secondes
ok allez suivant alors intéressant
foulée de alors foulée de caisse qui
fait il veut défendre le pion g7
ok bon c'est vrai il veut faire flouer
cinq échecs
il a deux idées
ce que j'aurais joué en partie je vais
vous dire après mais j'aurais pas de
rester très longtemps
beaucoup de maladresses et position
parce que j'ai l'impression que je suis
complètement gagnant et donc j'ai du mal
à trouver les coups les plus formés ok
mon cou en partie j'ai déjà trouvé
je vais pas vous le dire tout de suite
ce que je suis pas sûr que ce soit la
réponse est je veux pas vous influencer
mais la menace est fou et le 5
mais anigo ni super pour kaboom à moi je
vais mettre au chifoumi nous eh bien je
suis fou me temime chifoumi je vois
comment skype
désolé j'ai oublié le mettre sur occupés
mais ça peut être très très dangereux
quand on skype n'est pas sûr occupés on
peut avoir des messages de partout alors
j'attends un peu de voir beaucoup alors
mieux ce qui a quelque chose avec tours
pranger cet art tu as tout reprend g7
honnêtement j'aurais même pas regardé
fin j'aurais même par les jeter un coup
d'oeil mais après fou prend g7 je vois
pas du tout la plus value que ça d'avoir
donné la tour pour le pur pour le pion
tu vois j'ai même pas d'échec
voilà d'ailleurs qui dit le coup de
blitz et tous rêvent cinq mois tout
réflexe est ce que j'aurais joué le
tempo parce que je veux juste éviter fou
au sein qui est venir comment c'est un
petit peu ma c'est le roi avec du tour
h5 qui menace honnêtement je suis quasi
pas qu'elle est sûre je vois rien
d'autre de mieux mais ça m'étonne que ce
soit ce qui va nous donner comme coup
mais c'est peut-être juste ça dont on
dit tous rêvent 5 l on fait tous rêvent
c'est ce que j'aurais voulu l'exercice
résolu écoutez ce n'était pas très dur
on voulait juste éviter fou au 5 allée
suivant qu'à rallier 17
alors qu'est ce que veulent les blancs
ils veulent choper notre tour en réfute
bon
voilà coûté on sait très bien le coup
que j'ai envie de jouer mais je suis pas
sûr qu'il soit bon
il faut un peu plus on peut enfin un peu
plus calculer alors ses traits au noir
quelles sont vos idées
mais là encore le bon coup que c'est
sûrement le coup réflexe de blitz mai
c'est un peu dommage que c'est le coup
que tout le monde va dire sans avoir
vraiment calculé ça doit être cavaliers
prend h3 qui est en temps après sur
quels points h3 voilà je touche les
pièces à ce qu'il faut calculer ces
dames 6 échecs comment vous jouez sur
2,6 après qu'un maillage 3 parce que moi
j'ai essayé de vous faire les
entraîneurs tactique bien quoi le truc
c'est que je vais essayer ouvert
l'entraîneur tactique comme il faut
parce que le problème quand vous faites
lentement tactile comme on discute un
peu discussions de comptoir vous connais
vous faites le trafic à quel point je
crois c'est tentant vous partez vous
faites cas il prend h3 il se trouve que
là ça a sûrement être juste mais moi
j'ai envie que l'on dise que vous ce que
vous me dites ce que vous faisait face à
damas six échecs roigé cette dame 7
c'est qu'en fait le truc le petit piège
sur quelles épreuves trois dames 6 le
coup qu on aura envie de faire c'est
tour 5 f 7 mai ça perdrait tempo après
cavaliers f6 échec fourchette parce que
la tour et est clouée dans croit g7
c'est le bon coup mais c'est pas le poid
intuitif normalement normalement le coup
intuitif et tonton s'offrir what our f7
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu on va
tenter ça doit être ça à mes ok mais en
plus il fait d'un match 3 et je voulais
couler - piégeurs hockey est là comment
on finit ce truc là
alors bon je voulais être recherchée
comment vous finissez ici je vous
montrerai après
j'ai dit qu' on n'a pas le réflexe
d'analyser toutes les défenses possible
mais c'est le problème en fait que vous
faites l'entraîneur tactique c'est que
il n'ya pas le réflexe de tout faire ok
tout reprend tour et tous rêvent de le
grand classique mais ok le truc non
vérifiées avec ça encore un second ça
qu'on fait le truc tactique ans en un
c'est un vrai entraînement tactique là
qu'on en fait en train de faire les
tontons parce que je vous fait faire des
trucs comme on doit faire le truc c'est
que sur dame 6 faut bien voir le gros
piège c'est que si tu fais tour 5 f7 ce
que tu as normalement envie de faire
pour tout te protéger il ya cavaliers
six échecs et tu vas perdre la dame
donc ça c'est le gros piège et le truc
c'est que sur tours 8 à vii
non ça va pas c'est aussi parce qu'il
aura roi g7 après ça va les dames 8,3 g7
et il ya plus des chèques mais faut
aussi voir ça parce qu'il pourrait y
avoir des problèmes n'ayant pas de
problème est important d'avoir vu cette
variante et après sur dame prend h3g pas
montré mais ça a c'est le truc c'est que
j'aurais tout de suite que ça va gagner
perso parce que l'on va forcément
pouvoir dévier comme on l'a fait
et pour ceux qui répondent ça et d'amd 5
et qui nous dit double attaque le
problème tonton c'est que c'est pas une
double attaque parce que lecavalier
protéger ok on fait le suivant
oh là honnêtement j'aurais joué tempo
aussi braguette tempo lent mais sûr que
j'ai déjà trouvé
je suis sûr mais oui j'essaye de vous
faire l'entraîneur tactique à l'ancienne
comme si on était sur un bouquin ce que
moi mur tu as si quand je lui rendais
les exercices gérant des jeux rendait
pas le truc bien nicolas et toutes les
variantes
c'est faux quoi fin tu n'as pas juste tu
es obligé de trouver le truc à fond
alors on nous propose fou prend 1 h 6
mais est-ce que vous prend 1,6 et si
fort nous propose fou prend ainsi son
propre aux cavaliers h h5 pardon mais on
propose cavale et f5
alors lequel on vote on votre cave fois
je six cavaliers sam cooke avaler h5 y
en a un qui gagne tout de suite les
autres alors shepherd shepherd qui lui
dit dame g8 en défense et shepherd
shepherd qui a très juste sur x 6 ou
cavale et h5 on va faire dame g8 en
défense et on va défendre donc le coût
de ces cavaliers f5 pourquoi parce que
c'est une double attaque on a le pion à
6 en ligne de mire on va aller venger
et là encore on va aller à l'aller on va
les analyser les mecs ont mis longtemps
et donc là encore on va l'analyser le
truc sur cavaliers f5 c'est qu'on menace
cavaliers prend 1 6 3 et fuite et dames
g8 mat très fort et souvent les camions
arrivent ça qu'on dit que c'est des très
bonnes pièces offensives très bien placé
ok allez suivant trait au noir
classique
un grand classique du rire le cavaliere
5 de kasparov tony shepard shepherd
exactement le cavalier f5 très important
faut être précis aux échecs et cavaliers
f5 c'est le coup franc vite joué par
kuyt que j'ai envie de jouer de manière
assez intuitive qui ont une nouvelle
fois je sais pas pourquoi je vois ça
vient comme ça c'est qu'il ya des coups
à force d'avoir vu des parties d exemple
tu sais que ces cavaliers f5 ses coûts
qui lui en premier alors ici comment on
fait j'ai pas naître d'un 10 pour le
moment je vous laisse un peu réfléchir
cette charte qui nous propose 2 4 mai /
kg peut-être te faire [ __ ] en 1/4 et a
perdu en criant honte on sait cela enfin
il n'a pas encore trouvé
mais pour toi c'est un grand classique
du rif barba
c'est un grand classique
et shepherd shepherd qui la sépare parce
qu'il a donc le truc c'est qu'il vous
voyez que le fou détroit c'est une pièce
non protégés et si la dame arrive en e3
on va faire une double attaque
d'accord c'est comme ça qu'ils se
reconnaissent est dommage que j'ai pas
mes exercices de court parce que
j'aurais pu vous en montrer un autre
mais en gros c'est ed le mec va devoir
reprendre et dames trois échecs
c'est pas compliqué mais ça vaut le
rater les tontons en vite
honnêtement si vous avez pas qu'il a
acquis à la tactique vous l'a raté ça la
toussaint peut-être shepherd shepherd
mans mais tous les autres vous l'a raté
alors que c'est une tactique à trouver
donc là c'est une grosse erreur de la
part de tout le chat le chat en pls le
chat en pls vous auriez raté cette
tactique
voilà qui est des trois bons je pense
qu'on va pouvoir passer ça assez
rapidement en attendant je vous laisse
répondre un jeu allez je vais je veux
pas je m'auto ralenti quoi je suis même
pas sûr j'ai le bon coup
non mais c'est important que vous le
notiez ce qu'on va là on fait du grand
entraîneur tactique ins et je pense que
c'est mieux de le faire avec tonton
kevin l'entraîneur tactique que de le
faire tout seul je pas ce que vous en
pensez à vous pouvez m'écrire dans le
chatt moi je préfère le faire ça nous
avec le tonton kevin je réussis je
progresse plus parce que je j'ai les
explications là en live d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant pour moi si vous êtes
complètement d'avoir damé répondait
répondait de manière objective 1 allée
20-20 qu'il a on a le le fou des quatre
ans l'air donc il faut gagner le kilo
cavaliers en d3 parce que le pion c4 est
cloué et on va prendre de la tour comme
ça en protège le food et 4 il prend ici
on prend saddam et il abandonne
si on était mieux classé 15/2 rincon
alors cette charge non je pense pas que
que notre ami shepherd trouve plus vite
que moi je vais pas très vite alors si
on prend b4g un peu regarde le chat
avant de me lancer et que vous me dites
pas que vous préférez le faire seul ou
avec moi du plu seront préférés seul
mais peu importe
alors là tu reverras pour il a fait puis
on prend les cadres il aurait pas pu
prendre la lada à ça devait être un fou
ok donc on a notre dame emprise
on a notre dame emprise ouais bon ok
j'ai trouvé mais je me tais vous êtes
d'accord
kevin j'ai peur supporter qui est
d'accord les mairies qui préoccupe tu
préfères avaient convergé truc c'est que
vous force à réfléchir à toutes les
lignes donc quand il y en a plusieurs
ça vous oblige à un petit peu utilisez
votre cerveau pour tout calculer et de
faire les choses normalement parce que
non mais je vous connais les mecs je
vous connais dites moi dans le chat si
j'ai raison dans les commentaires sur
youtube si j'ai raison mais je suis sûr
que dans 90% des cas vous calculez pas
tout et vous jouez au feeling vos lignes
j'en suis sûr
on nous propose du kava lieux saints car
sur le carré de 5 heures et qui prend b3
et a pas de matin et yaz rigueur 90 qui
a la bonne réponse en vigueur 90 là où
il est défensive waka dernier menacé et
il voit aussi que la dame blanche elle
venir en f3 pour mettre un petit échec
désagréable donc nous propose de faire
kelly prend des quatre comme ça on va
dévier la dame au passage on a lu forcé
à prendre faut savoir qu'aux échecs les
coups les plus fort c'est ce sont les
échecs et les prises ensuite on va
ramener notre dame en f3 on va mettre un
échec et là c'est important de voir que
le cavalier tient f6 le foot y'a f7 et
le lacazette senghor elle est tenue et
maintenant le roi obligée d'allonger 8
parce qu'il ya le fou qui contrôle la
diagonale et on va finir avec un petit
cavale sept des familles un petit match
tranquille ok ça va
donc alors allé au suivant où là le mec
est courageux lecavalier prend c3 déjà
ce qu'on voit c'est que le roi est un
peu dans la merde je sais ce que
j'aurais fait en partie mais je suis pas
sûr que ça marche
c'est un marché
c'est joli c'est sympa
alors j'ai peur ni ton premier set tempo
ouais mais alors il faut vendre jusqu'au
bout shepherd
parce que dire pour preuve cette terre
tempo c'est facile mais il faut tout
voir mais je crois qu'il ya deux
manières de gagner même il y en a une
plus jolie colloque d'ailleurs
je crois qu'il ya un truc très joli
d'ailleurs je crois que j'ai un truc
assez joli
mais faut calculer tout reprend f7 faut
calculer juste que vous faut voir les
variantes
donc c'est assez classique car alors là
il y aurait deux manières de jouer en
réalité la manière ainsi tu veux pas
trop sacrifier ses jouets de 4 avec
l'idée de faire fou g5 fief si ces dames
g7 mat sur leucate j'imagine que les
noirs répondre par fous ses limites et
on n'a pas le temps de faire fou g5 donc
le fonds va le mettre ici à cause de
dame prend des quatre échecs et dame
prend 1,5 et peut-être cafu et fils
quand même donc je me demande si le 4 sa
gagne pas déjà honnêtement mais c'est
peut-être show peut-être eu quatre
pouces et 8 fou g5 dame prend des quatre
ouachin dame provokat fief si ce
d'apprendre quoi renflouer ce système
prend 1,4 et cavaliers je sais pas
peut-être que ça marche pas pas du tout
sûr que quatre marches
ok la deuxième idée c'est le truc le
plus direct c'est de faire tours fc 3f
cette dame hc3 f8
hélas après il peut y avoir plusieurs
idées moi le truc avec lequel j'aurai
essayé de finir c'est par fou pranger 6
je suis pas sûr que ça je suis pas sûr
que ça marche parce que ton problème
c'est trois points f cette dame proche
ces trois fuites c'est sûr qu'il ya un
match
alors peut-être il faut faire re 4
plutôt pour menacer fouache 6 il va être
obligé de couvrir le truc et on pourra
faire foi htc tour f1 dans tous les cas
je pense que c'est ça la réponse
parce qu'on nous dit dames 1 tours fc 3f
cette dame hc3 f7 dame alors ce qu'on
lit dans lequel je vais montrer une
litho à vii drive cette dame à vii trois
fuites mais voyons nous dit la variante
on nous donne
damas huit cavaliers g8 est fou à 3
alors ça je suis d'accord les tontons
mais sur damas huit cavaliers g8 s'est
pas forcé la roya c'est aussi mais
peut-être que sur wife 7 on peut faire
damev six échecs croit g8 mais je sais
pas moi perso ce que j'aurais dit ce4 ce
que j'aurais dit perso ce4 menace flash
six cavaliers f5
puis on prend f5 et le fonds arrive
quand même à ralph 6 et sur e4
qu'avaliser 8 x 3 échecs tout reprend à
3 tours eux en échec à
ça va faire maths aussi et cavaliers f6
tout reprend f6 d'un problème si sion
prend un f6 si on doit avoir d'alger
cette note à la fin mais il ya peut-être
aussi fou pranger si ce qu'il ya il faut
prendre les six cavaliers pranger 6 ha
dont il est fou prend je lis ici aussi
cavalier e 2 et chaque intermédiaire à
calculer ce que fout pranger six
cavaliers pranger 6 oublier ses forces
et des fous pranger si je fais car a
lieu deux vous faites 3g de jeu fait
cavalier pranger 6 vous faites x 3 je
fais tout reprend à 3 et quand vous
faites tout bref un échec fait cavalier
g cavaliers f4 effet qu'il ya plus mat
donc attendez les mecs parce que vous me
dites cette variante vous me dites cette
variante mais moi j'essaie de vous
compterez vous dit fou g6 forcé mais moi
je fais car il y eu deux cavaliers eu
deux échecs intermédiaire est ce que
c'est si fort c'est que ça ce que je
suis ce que je dis souvent votre défaut
c'est que vous cassez que vous calculez
pas assez juste vous calculez pas assez
juste les mecs souvent vous voyez votre
variant lycée bon moi je vous fais des
coûts intermédiaires de partout je suis
une fouine donc sur flu progressif
ricard a lieu deux rois j'ai deux
cavaliers pranger 6 x 3 tours prend à
droite ou bref un cavalier f 4g deux
tours de plus c'est un fou je dis ça je
dis rien alors qui est d'accord qu'il
n'est pas d'accord qui partent pour eux
4 qui part confié six matches parcouru 4
persos au moins j'ai j'évite les coûts
intermédiaires
alors à quoi ça sert cavaliers de vinça
sahara et je les montre allez on va
montrer je vais faire re 4 je pense que
c'est la bonne réponse
il fait g5 donc il va prendre vraiment
oui souci ok on a gagné mais je vais
vous montrer la fouine a échoué une
fouine
l'idée s'est prise prise ça ça surfe ou
g6 d'ailleurs ça gagne pas fou g6 à
cavani eux deux et vous allez voir tout
le fond l'idée roigé de cavaliers
pranger six fois croit tout reprend à 3
tours f1 et cavaliers f4 et le fond
l'idée c'est que j'ai les deux cavaliers
qui tiennent la case f4 à laver faut
calculer les mecs 1 aller 1
et ça c'est des exercices qui sont qu'à
2001 c'est pour ça que je dis les gens
il y à 2065 l'exo c'est juste que les
gens ils hoeft
il enchaîne en les mecs
alors là évidemment on peut continuer
éventuellement comme dit l'inventeur
d'un projet 6 mai cavalière quatre
échecs quand même format donc si au lieu
de tours f1 ont fait d'armes pranger 6
en se disant ok mais je menace tour f1
matin par able et ben imparable non j'ai
fait cavaler f4 je te mets le cavalier
emprise tu es plus ou moins obligés de
bouffées de cavale parce que tu as la
dame emprise et maintenant dames 7 et u
pas une position complètement gagnante à
un truc complètement perdre mais on y
faut pas venir en g2 mais ça change rien
que tu viens manger ou pas si tu viens à
schaerbeek après avec avec le roi c'est
pareil je vais quand même te faire qui
est étranger ici tu vas faire x 3 je
vais faire ça et quand tu vas faire
touré fins mais pareil faire cavalier f4
potage mettre l'autre cavagnan afghane
d'ailleurs plutôt pour éviter de me
prendre des trucs
mais je veux juste que vous sentiez la
différence enfin je le répète évidemment
mais bon la pédagogie c'est se répéter
mais
mais je vous répète un truc important si
vous voulez vraiment progresser avec un
entraîneur tactique
il faut faire ce boulot il faut faire ce
boulot c'est à dire essayer de calcul à
fond voir toutes les variantes c'est pas
grave si vous mettez du temps c'est pas
grave si vous avez du mal ou quoi il
faut tout voir
évidemment vous n'allez pas à progresser
énormément en termes de lots sur
l'entraîneur tactique parce que il faut
les résoudre vite et quand on va vite on
voit pas tout juste et pointe 8 y fait
souvent les crocs intuitif c'est lé bon
coin faut pas se faire d'illusions c'est
aussi un peu le souci parfois c'est que
c'est trop les coûts intuitif qui marche
ce qui fait qu'à prononcer plus calcul
en partie qu'on envoie des pièces ont
fait de la merde mais bon au bout d'un
moment si vous voulez y arriver parce
que là la réputation elle n'était pas
facile à trouver mais c'est ça qui va
vous permettre de faire le gap entre
quelqu'un qui tu vois un joueur du
bistrot qui envoie les pièces et qui
fait de la merde en gros un peu comme
moi donc un mec juste envoie cette
attaque et tu fais de la merde et
quelqu'un qui va vouloir vraiment
progresser bien calculer si tu veux bien
calculé faut qu'ils fassent le boulot ne
s'est trouvé les défenses de fer la
fouine a les prochains exercices
alors là alors là mon petit monsieur
très haut blanc
très haut blanc dire que je bloque un
petit peu jusqu'à faire toutes ces
explications je me ralentit un peu le
cerveau mais je pense que j'ai trouvé
alors nous faisons or qui dit est-ce que
tu donnes des cours info de taille sur
mon site bitstream point fr et tu peux
trouver ouais je donne des cours
alors me dire où pranger ici ça alors
sur fou prendre dès 6h pranger et 6 et
surtout 8 qui aura pas mal parce que le
roi s'échapperont h7
alors on nous propose le bon truc dans
le chat est là en calcul jusqu'au bout
tous vos huit cavaliers fuite
dams et 5 menace le cavalier est sûre
dams un échec fou f1 bien vu la dame
couvre la diagonale donc plus d'échecs
et dames croyait fit est imparable
bien joué suivant à c'est un bon truc
bourg ans donc il ya plein de trucs il y
à une association
voilà il ya plein de trucs qui gagne ou
alors là il ya plusieurs réponses à mes
choix qui un match complètement force et
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il ya une
variante complètement forcé
tian et denis c'est pas faux alors
surtout bessette shepherd y avait d'un
point à 8,1 tout à l'heure aux armes ni
trop bien le site merci tonton c'est moi
qui les fais tout seul comme un grand
pous bleus pour cap je m'auto mais des
pousses bleus
alors les tontons allez on fatigue l'
empathie allemagne way ces dames f4
assez facile d'un mec 4g trois forces et
du coup cavaliers pranger quatre âgés
forcé et h pranger trois double échec et
mat
on aurait pu aller plus vite en vue
qu'on rame un peu hâlé prochain tour 8
bon vous avez une première réponse mais
s'il n'y a pas plus fort
ce casque aime tellement simpliste que
tu te dis faire plus fort femme n'avait
pas l'impression
j'ai pas l'impression
dans mon propre aux 17 mai sur 17
peut-être fou prend 17
quoique ouais moi j'aurais juste tout
pris en 8 est pris à trois personnes
mais bon
j'ai vraiment beaucoup de mal à y ces
exercices mais où j'essaye de voir trop
loin souvent mais vous pensez des sept
plus fort je ne serai pas embarrassés
avec 17,1 mais bon puisque 17 j'aurais
eu peur de prises prix détour des
limites
j'aurais juste tout prix et j'aurais
juste tout prix en 8es prix h3 bêtement
bah écoutez ça c'est les exercices qui
m'énerve percée toujours eu des mâles et
résoudre je ne comprends pas le problème
profond du truc en fait parce que tmg et
si ce genre wife de dams et de troyes et
chaumont écoute on va faire ça comme ça
bon c'était ça mais là j'ai pas compris
le l'exercice en fait non mais sur 17
déjà brillant mais fou prend 17 qui
gagnait le pion donc déjà se fait 17 au
pire il est déjà fou prend 17 et c'est
moins bien mais en fait ce que je me
demande c'est juste c'est ce que je peux
arrêter ton pions en fait plus bêtement
déjà froissé c'est le premier truc que
j'ai vu qui a fait que j'avais déjà
envie d' éliminer parce que c'était déjà
moins fort que tous points 8 logiquement
mais il ya toujours des 8 et tour des
huit
mais c'est un problème quand même je me
rase tout reprend 17 est bon mais massif
et tours 8 je prends tu prends je prends
tu prends je prends tu prends mais j'ai
la même position
déjà j'étais même pas obligé de prendre
d'ailleurs mais là déjà même position
sans le pion des donc j'ai aucun intérêt
à jouer ça et en plus surtout huit je
peux aussi faire rage cette saison n'a
pas parlé c'était juste montrer droukdel
qui a minima faisait qu'on n'allait pas
jouer ça bon honnêtement j'ai pas trop
compris l'exercice
ok bon ça je connais l'exercice déjà
juste ça j'ai déjà vu la chine craint la
chambre ça comme je n'ai même pas besoin
de réfléchir je connais la position
javier exercice ya longtemps elle gagne
alors dame proche
voilà je suis là elle est connue il est
facile et simple la chance est là on
fait comment
on fait quoi maintenant libre et 1600 on
fait comment qu'on est là dans les jeux
monde parce qu'un peu de délai dame
prend h7 prise si l'on prend ça et
gratuit de maths à ils nous ont mis 2240
pour celui-là a là rien ne va plus très
haut noir je pense avoir trouvé direct
mais non à taq taq taq taq moi ça marche
pas si ça marche pas et attendez il est
pas si facile je suis là je veux arrêter
un truc ultra simple c'est le chat qui
va me le dire le chat va trouver avant
moi c'est sûr
non mais attends ces jeux bugs j'ai un
bug alors on nous dit tour d un ouais
mais le problème sur tours d1 c'est
qu'il a tout reprend g7 les mecs
attendait mais surtour diaryatou reprend
g7 vous êtes très rapide en besogne à
vous dit tout son retour des 1
mais tours pranger cet échec
tour d un âne de tout reproche et cet
échec et vous fin vous êtes refroidi
quand même inquiétant points à 7 on
prend 1,7 et or des inrocks mais
attendent et on prend à sète on prend à
7 tours d un tour pranger cet échec
alors attendez attendez il ya tout un
tas de gens qui répondent moi je suis
une réponse alors fou pranger de dames
pranger de hongwu projet de dames frangé
deux tours d'un échec crois-je deux
dames des six bon ok je fais f4 et en
gros je t'ai refroidi on nous dit dame
pranger de mai sur dame franges et 2
d'un projet 2 de tutti tour d un échec 3
h 2 tu es complètement perdant me faut
une réponse complète pour manger que des
trucs perdants ben hamaibi bye bye
j'imagine qui part
ok david roussel qui a le bon truc donc
on fait tout reprend à 7 ans premier
tour prend à 7
on a des bonnes réponses de partout
autour des 1 et maintenant la grande
différence c'est qu'après tout reprend
j'ai cette dame prend g7 il n'y a plus
la tour qui peut venir manger et donc on
peut prendre en f1 parce qu'on se fait
pas prendre sur échec je vais bien leur
montrer suis là parce que il ya eu des
erreurs de partout ça a été la prs
mystique
parce que vous m'avez fait du tour d un
qui perdait après d'un tour pranger
cette dame prend g7 et tout reprend g7
sur échec
donc vous n'avez pas le temps et vous
allez perdre la tour donc ça vous m'avez
raconté du caca on a eu du drame pranger
deux dames projet de tour des 1
mais après rouages de ya plus d'échecs
et c'est complètement fou tu n'y a pas
de maths du couloir ça aurait marché si
le pion était en h2 mais là ça marche
pas donc ça ça permet aussi on a eu du
fou pranger de dames projet de tour des
échecs rouages de d'anne decis qui
paraissait malin mais qui perd tout de
suite après f4 et là tu te fais tu te
prends une contre attaque de feu angers
c'est ta pièce de moins aidé à me
prendre et 7 matteau prochain donc on a
eu toutes ces mauvaises réponses
et finalement on est sûrs et tonton du
bled qui nous ont mis un petit tour
prend 1,7 en premier du coup on force
plus ou moins tout reprend 1,7 et après
tour d un maintenant quand il prend g7
on prend g7 et on se fait plus reprendre
sur échec donc on a le temps de
récupérer la dame est évidemment dimpre
en d1 n'était pas jouable à cause de
dames pranger de maths ça va les tontons
là vous seriez ramasser comme des merdes
1 franchement il faut le dire aussi un
giroud dans mon faut être franc a
atteint une finale
bon je comprends pas trop pour le moment
le problème profond l'exercice george
mitchell a été bien bah ouais ça vous a
fait une belle mise en pls suis là j'ai
peur ni comme des blues aimeraient vous
allez trop vite
ah ok marin qui a dit à ses 7 et ça
gagne tout de suite elle a juste très
important de faire roi prend g4 pour
éviter fouet 5
ok et là j'imagine qu'on fait un
cavalier et que ça gagne pas ce que
j'avais pensé de base mais je vérifier
qui est pas mieux
parce que en faut quand même calculer
ses huit fou aux six prises prise roi c5
mais je pense que le pion à varades à
mon premier mais je vais une caution
fait un cavalier parce que drake section
fin cavaliers ils feront à b 8 ont fait
à cet échec et il va devoir
on va avoir une fourche est tombé 6 avec
le cavaliere donc c'est une sous
promotion
le petit problème c'est que j'ai pas si
je peux faire les sous promotion
je n'ai pas les sous promotion
je suis dans la merde comment fait des
sous promotion paramètres c'est où
parra met enfin que j'allais prendre là
sous projets et faire la soupe promotion
tac tac tac c'est ou déjà paramètres
on fait comme on fait comment faire et
sous promotion déjà
sur promouvoir en dames et du coup avoir
pour voir en cavale ok maintenant à
faire un petit à cet échec car l ipv6 et
france et 4 est ok là y'a un truc
important à vous montrer encore on va
aller plus loin dans cet exercice
on va aller plus loin dans cet exercice
en fait le truc c'est qu'ensuite le
cavalier fait un mur et après à 4 3 f 6
à 3 cavaliers prend roi ici alors voit
ici parvenir on apprend à vii le
problème c'est que lecavalier et
extérieurs au carré du pion d'accord ça
c'est le carré du pion d'accord et donc
toutes ces cases là elles sont dans le
carré donc le roi peut aller dessus
ok tout ça c'est le carré du pion mais
ces cases là le roi peut pas aller
dessus vu que lecavalier extérieur au
carré le pion est inattaquable
ok ça va pour tout le monde
allez on va au suivant
tejada metz 4e place envie de d'aller
mater comme des fouines
j'ai pas trouvé encore j'ai pas mal
d'idées mais j'ai pas trouvé
ok j'ai un truc pas mal j'ai un truc
joli mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit ça
j'ai un truc assez jeudi
si je parle anglais il ya ça explique
english petit ce friendstream sol
alors quitte à lui dam des trois alors
dame b3 déjà deux options options numéro
un tour f7 comment on continue à près
d'1 b3 surtout rev7
alors
tombé huit mâts toqué donc sur dan b3
roi suite comment vous continuez
est-ce que ça a été écrit on me dit dame
b 2 échecs ok mais sur dames les deux du
fer bammer 6 et vous allez faire d'un
probable tout reprend hockey est tombé
huit matches ok c'est ça on va faire dan
b3 échec
donc l'idée pourquoi dans le détroit
plutôt dames 6 parce que l'on veut
garder la connexion avec la casse b8 tué
montré après la tour des huit bon c'est
pas m'atteindre cas d'un premier 8 mais
c'est tout comme
ok juste petit truc important c'est que
sur dame 6 roi je crois je suis toi là
vous ne pouvez plus faire des chèques
sur la grande diagonale
donc vous êtes bloqués et les noirs
menace d'un problème de donc c'est mort
d'accord en revanche après dame b 2
après dun baies 3par dont vous avez et
le dame ses trois échecs qui va rester
pour la grande diagonale et un contrôle
sur la case des huit qui fait pas de mal
et donc suroît je suis vous allez
pouvoir faire dame c3 ou d'un bep 2 je
pense que les deux marchés et sur dan f6
qui couvrent ou sur n'importe quoi qu'il
y en ait six vous avez mètres la tour en
b vite pour l'absurde a même si l'on
peut soit faire d'un principe si souvent
moi j'aurais fait le plus joli donc il
ya un problème 6 tourcoing fc tours des
nuitées on va mater moi j'aurais fait
autour des huit pour le bo c'est plus
beau c'est plus esthétique mais c'est
moins forcé ne vous amusez pas à faire
ça en partie mais c'est plus joli de
faire tourner vite assez beau jeu quoi
quand tu fais du stream pas envie
d'avoir un peu de beau jeu s'il prend on
prend et s'il ya là on prend saddam il
est bloqué c'est le beau jeu on lit sur
dame c3 et la tour f 6 mais surtout m6 à
tourbes et imite quand même dame prend
des huit d'emprunt f6
3 g 8 et d'ériger cette phrase
n'excusait tarifs dam des deux était un
peu plus précis du coup c'est jusque
ayant fui cette variante ça fait pas de
différence mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être plus plus simple dames les
deux à les suivants très haut blanc
alors ça j'ai déjà vu quelque part
du coup j'ai le premier coup qui me
vient tout de suite en tête
ouais ok c'est marrant mais m'ont juste
je connais déjà quelque chose de
similaire un jeu qui n'est peut-être pas
ce truc précis mais juge a lu un truc
similaire
du coup non c'est 7 mai faut calculer
plus loin de tours c'est cette eau qui
ont ils découverte à répétition donc 20
qui a trouvé donc lorsqu'on va faire
c'est ce qu'on appelle un moulin c'est à
dire qu'après tour ses sept
il va être obligé de prendre 1 h 5 on va
faire un échec en recettes et en gros ce
qui va se passer
non c'est pas céder ce que je peux
laisser à partir pour voir et ils ne
jettent pas qui a joué ce truc la peau
écoutez peut-être que j'avais jamais vu
un
juste un truc ensemble on va faire tout
recette est en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que maintenant on peut pas tout
rasé en fait en apprendrons bessette
il va revenir ce qu'on appelle un moulin
on va revenir on va revenir on va
revenir et vraiment qu'on a rasé tout ce
qu'on pouvait rasé 1
on ne peut pas prendre plus de pièces
sur cette colonne donc on a tout pris
maintenant on va raser ce qu'il ya de
gros ici donc sur le sur la ligne comme
ça où aller quand vous êtes ici en fait
une fois que vous avez tout raser sur la
7ème vous raser le plus gros truc sur
une colonne bon elle a évidemment le
plus gros truc c'est la dame aura donc
vous revenez il repart et vous prenez la
dame
ok suivant
bon c'est pas très dur c'est pas très
dur alors très haut blanc
je pense que ce truc là s'appelle le mat
de à quelque chose près le mag de
pillsbury ce qu'on va voir là dans
l'esprit ailleurs nous propose fou prend
g7 ya peut-être plus simple option qui
n'aura pour propre aux cavaliers f6 le
faux calculs étude ifop ranger set mais
après tu as faim fou ce que peut-être ça
marche un mais qui avoue pranger s'être
rapproché 7
de brito 6 dames j'ai trois fois m6 m'a
adressé sa truc c'est que sur coup franc
mais ce n est pas ça marche matin truc
très simple qui a valu à six pions prend
force et sinon il ya la dame qui tombe
dame j'ai trois rois shoots forcés
bon je veux aussi me mets mon envoyé
avec laurent a chuté tu vas faire fut
problème si ce math schéma de match
classique le truc c'est que vous
prendrez set je sais pas tu vas tu t'en
vois une pièce dans le désert comme ça
je te bouffer dame j'ai trois rois je
suis tête à plus d'échecs quoi t'as pas
d'âme c3 ces contrôles et à plus d'
échec et je vais te faire tout rejet
limité je vais venir te masser tu vois
je vais trop froid dire quoi tu fait
cavaler m6 maintenant je te fais dam des
caps double attaque
enfin gros t'es complètement foutu donc
attention à ne pas envoyer des pièces
trop vite parce que je pense que vous
prendrez sept sapeurs sur le champ à les
dames f3 alors qu'est ce qu'on lui fait
à celui-là
comment le cuisine
je pense que les trouvères et je suis
pas sûr à 100%
une idée si c'est tentant mais moi aussi
ça me tente mais a beaucoup de trucs à
calculer donc faut calculer les mecs
peut-être que des 6 mars est ce que ça
marche pas faut tout calculer comme
d'hab il faut vous appreniez à faire cet
effort
un produit tout reprendre cet art je
pense que surtout reprend 2,7 ya dame
prend à agen mais des six faut calculer
faut faire l'effort
on dit des six tours 8 dames condamnons
alors des six sur d'un prendra mais a pu
compenser cet échec on apprend ses 7es
tout reprend achats
donc d ici sur pu emprunter 6 faut vous
calculez ce qu'il faut faire c'est pas
si simple
j'ai trouvé mais alors on nous dit alors
là complètement la rue antoine bourges
était complètement la rue un désolé mais
tu ris tour cette dame prend à chaque
tour huit échecs 3,17 et tour sept
matches alors déjà ce tu bouges à tour
eu un set était cloué chat a pas le
droit
et en plus surtout recettes sûrs et tout
reprendre cette corvée des sourires mais
s'est sorti tout seul alors critique une
idée si on prend des six dames h suite
alors sur wade cette première variante
dames 8 maths et surtout refi tours 8
donc cristal qui nous montrent la bonne
variante un calcul est donc des six en
fait le truc c'est qu'on venait à se
prendre et je vous montrerai afrique est
une menace très forte
maintenant on fait damage fuite pour
venir faire d'amis huit échecs et mat et
surtout refi de contre on a tout revu
huit échecs 3e set et on va prendre la
fuite
jamais on peut faire j'aurai tout
reprend et fut ton parti chez parce
qu'il est plus fort et c'est encore plus
fort mais bon j'ai la flemme
ok c'est juste
alors des six ok là dessus ce qu'il
fallait voir c'est que sur un coup de
tours lambda j'imagine conception prend
1,7
bon on s'y prend 1,7 ont gagné du
matériel et si bouger le roi en 8 on
avait toujours d'un match 8 échecs qui
ont passé en force
donc ça ils pouvaient pas du coup sûr
des six perso je pensais qu'ils
joueraient dame prend achat des français
c'est trois français sets et 3 h et la
position est loin d'être gagnante c'est
probablement possible de tenir là nul
donc ça ça doit être nul à moi c'est
gros avantage blanc et c'est chiant à
défendre mais je pense que ça doit être
défendable peut-être qui sait donc
étendu difficile à dire peut-être ces
gagnants comme je sais pas si on peut
faire une forteresse ou pas dur à dire
mais bon ok c'est déjà très bien vu
qu'on part avec une pièce de moins a
fini avec une kalach de plus et donc
surprise voilà ce qu'il fallait bien
voir c'est d'un match 8 et et touré
fille tour lui très important brink
lycées avant qui me saouler je voyais
pas le gain direct ouais mais bon c'est
la vie est dure par la queue ok ça gagne
parce qu'il n'y pas que l'on parle de
trop loin par de trop loin on peut pas
toujours être gagnant 1 alors qu'ils ont
progressé 1,4 et au blanc alors il y en
a partout
nêne partout
voilà c'est typiquement genre d'exemple
pas si évident que ça pour le moment je
trouve pas ça je suis capable de pas
trouvé
le truc m'inspire ah ok j'ai compris
j'ai compris j'ai compris ouais ok il
faut aussi soyez pas très dur en fait
alors non c'est pas la dame enfermé
cristal parce que sur fouet si adam
prend h4 c'est pas la dame enfermé non
non enfouis 62.4 la dame a pas être
enfermé avec sommes très très attention
c'est pas faut aussi c'est avec cette
idée là c'est vrai qu'une autre idée
dans quelle idée
or death est exact c'est la double
attaque et du coup il fait dame prend
1,6 pour éviter qu'ils avaient les
points le 6 mai c'est pas du tout la
dame enfermé en fait bizarre d'ailleurs
que l'ordinateur répondre d'un prendre 6
quand tu vas jouer dame prend h4 plus
tôt ok ça va être moins fort parce qu'il
faut voir ça mais c'est ça qu'il faut
voir
c'est cette variante pas qu'il faut
calculer et c'est vrai que celui sur
l'entraîneur tactique qui a mis fou
aussi ce qu'ils pensent ou et damages 5
gigas gens ferment la dame
en fait il n'a pas vraiment trouvé le
truc ce que le truc qui fait d'armé si
ce qui prend du 6 et du coup lui donne
l'exercice quelque part dans ok à l'onf
est le suivant fou g7
honnêtement là j'aurais juste tempo ne
fallait pas très longtemps
kike des 5 perso j'aurais caïds et 5
tempo mieux 5 marche peut-être aussi
mais je serai cavaliers j'ai pas
calculer plus loin en raid 1 du coup
peut-être cinq est plus fort chez pas
quelqu'un qui apprend des quatre
épreuves six échecs et après et est à
qu'à rallier derrière quatre sérieux
s'ils souhaitent sûrement 25
sûrement plus tôt au 5 km s'inquiéter 3
6 3
huit cavaliers qu'elle est née 5 et des
quatre épreuves ces chèques croyais fit
d'un f4 cavalier e 6 fourchette
ça doit être le 5 pour des raisons
tactiques ça doit être le 5 mai j'aurais
plutôt et 5 en partie à taper ça je vais
montrer pourquoi je pense qu'ils les
dessins que ça marche pas pour un truc
très concret qui est prendrait quatre
est sûr qu'il prend les 6 3 f 8 et d'un
f4 seul casse pour rester au contact du
cavalier et là-dessus cavaliers aussi
sévère de taper le fouet le cavalier et
on peut jamais faire du kayak
cette prise est prise parce que ratures
la dame en prise à la fin mais peut-être
que là dessus on peut peut-être faire
d'emprunt f6 fou prend et fils fou prend
f6 dame bouche quelques pas mal à mettre
en scène huit et prendra la suite
peut-être on peut jouer comme ça et
c'est quand même bien parce que on a
deux pièces et une tour pour la dame on
attaque encore le cavalier doit bouger
le cavalier quelque part je suis pour à
dire qu'à radio ici c'est matériellement
n'est quand même devant donc ça doit
quand même marché divisé sur cinq
cavaliers à 5 au début web alors au cinq
cavaliers à 5 ça n'a pas grande
importance un bon alors on peut juste
faire n'importe quel coût de dames le
clouage va rester il ya même un truc
marrant c et puis on prend vous prend et
on prend menace la tour de la dame
qui est peut-être plus joli et dalphond
qui reste sans prise genre tu dois faire
un tour g8 souffrent des huit tours
prend des huit cahiers première 3
mais dans mon problème si ce nom mais ça
doit être le truc avec les dessins que
ça c'est un avantage pour moi
l'évaluation de sa ces avantages plan
clairement ça les blancs sont mieux
c'est sûr il ya avantage matériel on a
cinq pions contre x que contre cette
marée se mettre nue pour les blancs ça
il ya beaucoup de pièces le roi noir est
mal placé n'y a pas d'activité sas
avantage de lancer sur ok suivant baal
et ça c'est cadeau un petit coup de
fatigue là il faut des exo facile
comment on continue
donc ranger 3 avec le classique matin le
roi qui est bloqué bon
comment vous continuer ici ça
honnêtement j'avais pas vu comme vous et
d'un petit coup de pompe là je suis même
mois plus très rigoureux c'est pas bon
quand vous commencez à être fatigués la
com com suis en train de faire et ne pas
être rigoureux de pas penser à des coups
comme b4 et tous ces mauvais signe après
ça et que l'exercice était pas ultra
motivant parce que c'était gros comme
une maison
mais du coup c'est pas bon faut être
rigoureux bon alors là comment on fait
ben c'est juste fou prend b4 en fait un
qui va être pas mal mais il ya peut-être
plus fort
alors sur food & katz adam prend des
quatre qui me gêne un peu shepherd qui
joue sur le clouage du pion de 5
et elle position pareille food et 4
dames 3 et 4 ça me gêne un poil
fou des cas d'un projet 4 ça me gêne
après peut-être un truc que je vois pas
mais n'a pas été très heureux quoi fait
il ya deux écoles sont vains pour le fou
prend des 400 ha pour le fouet f2 mais
le fief de il est peut-être fouet f2 et
surtout bref un fou des 4 et surtout re
deux tours pour un f3 suivant ces faux
f2 une fois m dos faut aussi calculer
dame de mesdames de prendre mais cette
fois f2 même peut-être rien qui cloche
un mage upi mais bon faut calculer il ya
plein de coups en fait c'est juste que
je ne comprenais pas je me répète et je
me répète et tout ça j'ai tout ce qu'il
faut f2 c'est quoi le problème bafoue tu
calcules tu aurais fait un tour deux
dames 2 faut voir tous les comme c'est
sais pas si automatique quoi c'est
peut-être qu'ils ont pensé si ces
intermédiaires
il ya peut-être un coup de foot tu vas
faire ya des trucs quoi mais on peut pas
aller si vite mais ça me paraît bon
fèves de foued deux tours et fin mai fu
des 4 après 20 du coût mais surtour de
tourcoing f3
houphouet f2 tour 2 et latour premiers
froids comme ça je protège et un
papillon prend à cause de dame prend
mais il faut bien voir les mecs un
désolé si je suis un peu en train de
vous engueuler ou quoi c'est mon côté
c'est mon côté profs qui ressort mais
chiant mais fou et the way du coup faut
bien voir tour de tourcoing f3 ça gagne
tour f1 food et katia plus le clouage
énorme et on prend fin c'est mystique et
sur dame 2 pour menacer le fou du coup
fou prend l'un puis on prend g3 est fou
pranger 3 et on reste avec une pièce de
plus il faut voir tout ça faut voir tout
ça c'est dur c'est comme ça qu'on
apprend à calculer les tontons aller
tour f 5 voire optimiste à travers ça
j'ai plein d'idées une nouvelle fois
mais qui a été le plus efficace
non pas pour le moment sur la mauvaise
direction personnellement j'espère que
vous vous êtes dans la bonne direction a
requis à j'ai compris assez joli c'est
joli
alors cette chanson aux dames cette
version 2007 qu'est ce que font les
noirs pour défendre allez vous donne pas
les coups de défense qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec les noirs sur damas est pour
défendre je vous faire bosser moi tu vas
voir je vais vous faire bosser
/ ame cette tour f 7 et donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut faire damage 6 pour que
surtout rêve c'est ton nez dame prend
j'ai six échecs mais il y aura pas matin
par al des mcs a une nouvelle fois vous
n'allez pas jusqu'au bout sur dame
pranger ici ce qu'est ce qu'il va faire
avec et noir il va faire froid f8 à ils
vont pas jusqu'au bout dans l'exemple
non plus damages six tours fc est donc
c'est quasi forcée parce que sur wave
c'est tout à faire dame là et je n'aime
pas regarder très loin mais j'ai
l'impression qu'après rouaroua d82 avoir
poussé 5 et ça se sent qu'on va mater on
sait pas très bien de dire ça se sent
mais là quand même
pareil quand même très compromis pour
les noirs donc tous rêvent cette dame g6
roi fuite forcée et l'a probablement le
plus précis c'est fou ces cinq échecs
avec l'idée qu'il va faire sûrement des
six vous prendrez 6 et sur roy 8 on fera
à tour pranger le tour prend 1,7 alors
on a même d'un proxy ce peut-être mais
bonjour et moi j'aurai fait tout
reproche sept de base et on va aller
mater à la brutale quand même ça se voit
mais faut quand même mieux voir wife 8
quoi bein euh c'est pas mal de voir
qu'est une défense attention après ça
gagne mais c'est bien allez on va vers
le suivant
torah suite
intéressant
je rentre une nouvelle fois de calculs
et du caca bon alors en action 17 qui
est passé on a envie qu'ils aillent adam
mais sur dame 3,8 la tour prend 1,8
s'avance pas trop
et ça nous avance pas trop
ok pour moi je vois pas comment le passé
je suis sûr que le chat va le trouver
avant moi cela finalement ils vont
trouver un avant moi bon du coup en
partie ce que j'aurais fait à mon avis
ça aurait été simple et efficace
je vais vous dire après mais on voit pas
du tout comment passer le plombe le pion
des tous les sacrifier ce genre de truc
qu'on a envie d'essayer parce que c'est
en train tactique jardin f7 machin ça
n'a pas marché
ok ce que j'aurais fait c'est comme
adeline stream j'aurais fait aussi ce
jeu menace 7 pour dames et s'il fait
d'un point aussi ce qu'est le premier
coup a regardé à mon avis j'ai dame
prend à 8 et sur dame français 4 d'un
point f8 donc sur 6 apparemment d'un
pronom six daims prend 1,8 salif
salaires fort et sûr d'un prend 17
j'aurais d'un profit trois premiers
films tout reprend 17 donc eu 6 il va
être obligé de prendre du plomb et
là-dessus j'aurais joué dameuse 5 qui
menacent fou prend aussi c'est qu'ils me
donnent l'impression que je vais mater
et sur walf 7 pour défendre j'aurais
passé la roi le rôle à tous rendez 6
après je pense qu'elle 5 doit être
gagnant aussi mais je serais parti pour
russie ce perso voilà et sur dame prend
là j'aurais pris à 8
c'était la réponse
et sur fion prend 1,6 j'imagine que dame
5 est vraiment très fort parce qu'on a
un gros réseau de maton à la tour qui
rentrent en d6 intéressant cet exercice
là parce que c'était pas un gars si
direct et bravo aux mathes bitstream de
l'avoir trouvé c'était pas un bien si
direct c'était pas si simple est ok
allez on en fait un dernier pour la
route sachez que c'est un truc que j'ai
déjà vu quelques pas
alors comment on fait ça
comment on fait ça
comme cet ajout est nettement
c'est un peu plus dur cela alors on y
[ __ ] wael faux et trois gardes est bon
de magie ça me sautait pas aux yeux
j'ai bien fait de regarder le chat faut
3 ça va gagner ce sur dame prend 1,3 et
ses deux mains bien je le chat au moins
vous en aurez eu avant moi et ce avec
ses parts à jouer parce que tout le
reste ça marche pas
et ouais la lame est perdu est après
faut encore la gagner mais ça ça va être
gagnant on va s'arrêter sur celui-là on
va se faire un petit bilan des courses
alors qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé
ce que ça vous a plu
ce que ça vous a pas plu
est ce que vous préférez qu'on le joue
quoi mais ce qui est des choses à
améliorer
pas nous jeter un peu vos avis mme
peut-être un truc constructif et surtout
un pareil quand vous commencez à être un
peu fatigué vous avez du mal a calculé
que vous n'avez plus de rigueur dans vos
calculs
quand vous donnez plus rigoureux que
vous commencez juste à faire
l'entraîneur tactique par réflexe c'est
c'est hyper important d'arrêter
simplement faut juste arrêter dans ces
cas-là ça sert à rien d'aller plus loin
c'est juste que vous progressez pas vous
pouvez faire des tactiques après en
étant fatigué mais il ya plus de progrès
l'intérêt quand vous faites l'entraîneur
tactique c'est vraiment de calculer au
bout je le répèterai jamais assez c'est
hyper hyper hyper hyper important de
calculer un maximum de coups de voir un
maximum de deux variantes de voir un
maximum de défense et de tout calcul et
vous avez vu sur l'exemple où on hésite
et avec eux quatre tout à l'heure où
avec fu pranger 6 surtout prendre les
six avaient une variante de fouine assez
compliqué qu'il fallait absolument voir
il faut toujours être sur le qui vive si
vous voulez progresser faut toujours
chercher des défenses les plus fortes
hyper hyper hyper hyper hyper important
alors ce sera sur youtube antoine on met
généralement les lives en riant en
replay sur youtube de trois semaines
après celle sur un replay sur sur
twitter donc très important sur la 116
points comme deux twitch et sur le
youtube de check points comme les lives
sont toujours en replay notre façon oui
je comprends entre soissons ne peut pas
ralentir faut qu'on se pose faut bien
avoir le faut bien voir les coûts et
faut bien calculer jusqu'au bout je ne
le répèterai jamais assez
on a très peur métal qui est content il
c'est génial pour apprendre le calcul
mais si les gens qui n'ont pas aimé
n'hésitez pas à le mettre aussi un ne
pensais pas je voulais mettre un fond
c'est parce que j'ai rencontre quand tu
demandes un truc si ça vous a plu ta que
les gens qui sont heureux qu'ils étaient
riches soient heureux les gens du grand
beau moi je m'en foutais remarqué sont
déjà partir d'exercices vision duchess
comme moi je le ferai un de ces quatre
c'est pas c'est pas idiot merci matmat
bitstream pour pour le conseil et du
coup et si vous bossez la tactique comme
je viens de vous l'apprendre mais on
leur fera ensemble
vous allez progresser mais dix fois plus
vite que si vous faites les exercices
comme des abrutis
et si vous voulez faire la même truc
seul vous pouvez évidemment prendre un
abonnement hors sur check point com ou
un abonnement diamant ou en abonnement
comme vous voulez et comme ça vous
pouvez faire des petites sessions
tactique tous les jours comme on vient
de le faire ensemble
on est tous assez sur une chaise comme
vous pouvez vous pouvez vous abonner à
voir et à voir ces petites séances
tactiques et si vous faites on va dire
30 30 40 minutes intensif comme on l'a
fait surtout les premières minutes à la
fin on était un poil lent surtout moi
qui est censé être le maître de
cérémonie était un peu un peu moins
moins vif mais si vous faites ça 30 45
minutes par par jour vous allez faire
des progrès énormes mais c'est comme le
sport on le fait à fond le fait vraiment
je n'en fait pas des deux nippons que tu
vois c'est pas de la demi pont pour fait
de la vraie pompon fait vraiment des
pompes quoi on s'amuse pas à tricher
et oui les et chez les exercices sur le
contre alpha zorro sur check point comme
sont très bien choisis et sont de très
bonne qualité ce qui est hyper important
quand vous faites aussi des exercices
tactiques et vous entrez sur
l'entraîneur tactique c'est d'avoir des
bons exercices à vous avez vu les
exercices sont vraiment bien et c'est
important d'avoir de bons exercices et
les exercices sont mal choisis dans ces
cas là bas ça sera beaucoup moins c'est
beaucoup moins utile d'où l'intérêt
d'avoir un outil payant qui vous
permettra de vraiment progresser
donc voilà on fait pas des ont fait pas
des semis truc on fait pas du ce me
souvenais de macha non non on fait on
fait le truc jusqu'au bout sur ce les
mecs bas il est temps de vous dire à
bientôt prochain live sur la chaîne
tweet blitz stream ce sera lundi 21h
pour la réhabiliter on essaiera
d'envoyer du lourd et demain une vidéo
sur la chaîne youtube blitz crime avec
un nouvel invité sébastien joie qui
ferait un peu son arrivée qui nous
présentera une partie très intéressante
sur le système de londres sur ce je vous
souhaite à tous une excellente soirée
faites vous plaisir amusez vous bien
ciao les mecs